So you've been an educator through the rise of the smartphone.
And my question basically relates to procrastination and task delay,
needless task delay specifically and given the unprecedented level of
distraction that we have in today's world.
I just wanted to get your perspective from a psychological standpoint on other
than cleaning your damn room,
what would you suggest to a student who's looking to overcome these things?
Well,
I think with any,
let's call it an addictive process.
I mean emails powerfully addictive,
right?
Hardly it's,
it's a slot machine and I mean that technically.
So when you pull,
that's a variable ratio reinforcement schedule,
if I remember correctly.
And it's very addictive because if you pour on the slot machine arm enough,
you will win and you never know which pole will reward you.
And so not only is that addictive,
it's very hard to extinguish that.
And so
emails like that because there's always something beckoning and now and then
it's a jackpot.
And social media is like that because you know,
people are posting interesting things and so well how do you overcome an
addictive process?
And partly you do it by replacing it with something better.
Right?
So when people study drug and alcohol use,
they often make an elementary mistake,
which is to try to figure out why people use drugs and alcohol.
That's,
that's not a smart thing to wonder.
We know why people use cocaine.
Cocaine directly stimulates the systems that produce positive emotion.
It's like,
so there's no mystery there.
The mystery with cocaine is very,
very simple.
Why don't people take cocaine all the time until they die?
That's the mystery really.
Cause you can get isolated rats to do that.
So,
and,
and for some people,
alcohol has the same kind of effect except it's mediated by opiates.
But often what people have to do to get themselves out of an addictive process
is to find something better to do to replace it.
And so I would say the problem with the gadgets,
I mean there are amazing things is that they interfere with the proximately
interfere with medium to longterm goals,
I would say.
And so I think the first thing you have to do to bring them under control is
figure out what it is that their use is interfering with.
It has to be something important,
right?
So you think,
well,
I want to do something important.
What is that?
Or it could be personal.
Maybe you want to have a relationship.
You want to get married,
you want to have kids,
you want to have a career that's meaningful.
You know,
you want to have a life,
you want to have an Abrahamic adventure and be the father of nations,
let's say.
Well,
you can't be ratting away on your cell phone and doing that.
And so I think,
I think part of it is to set your sights high ed and make a plan and figure out
who you could be and see if obsessive utilization of smart phone fits into that
vision of nobility.
And it will,
partly because they're,
they're unbelievably powerful communication devices.
But so,
so often it's,
it's for lack of something better to do and it also interferes.
So that's about the best I can do with that.